El Duelo continúa en Tailandia a tres
días de los funerales una ceremonia
frente a la puerta de una guardería
donde escenas de familiares hicieron un
altar con las pertenencias de las
víctimas
en simultáneo una procesión y una
ofrenda en un templo budista
hoy todos los familiares realizarán una
ceremonia para guiar las almas de los
niños de regreso al templo luego
continuaremos realizando una sesión de
oración esta noche y mañana la cremación
se llevará a cabo aquí mismo no estoy
segura si alguien se le permite hacer la
ceremonia por su cuenta
pese a estar visiblemente es afectados
no todos los asistentes lloran pérdidas
algunos como el caso de PlayStation
esquivaron la desgracia de milagro
mi hija estaba durmiendo de Cara a la
pared y no vio nada tengo suerte que mi
hija esté bien pero perdí a mi prima
otras personas solo tienen un hijo y era
su Esperanza
mientras continúa el duelo de las
familias las preocupaciones
gubernamentales pasan por controlar las
consecuencias de la tragedia
si podemos proporcionar primeros
auxilios psicológicos adecuados y
estabilizar a la comunidad lo antes
posible esto dejará el menor impacto en
la próxima generación si no hacemos nada
la herida y el trauma estarán
incrustados
el último jueves un tirador ingreso al
centro de desarrollo de niños en utais
aguan y asesinó a más de 30 personas la
mayoría de ellos menores de edad
identificado como un Sargento de policía
el autor perpetró el atentado masivo más
mortífero de la nación el próximo martes
se hará la cremación de los cuerpos
según indican las creencias budistas